one of the questions i keep getting is
bitcoin poised for another breakout well
there's a brand new data point that's
worth paying attention to the 200-day
moving average bitcoin has been trading
below that for quite a while that yellow
line represents that 200-day moving
average and ultimately when bitcoin
breaks the 200-day moving average and
gets above it it tends to be quite
bullish but as we continue to hit up
against it but not cross over it people
want to know is this a head fake or are
we actually poised to see that breakout
there's articles and everything from
bloomberg all the way through other
publications pontificating on what's
going to happen if we go ahead and we
take a look at this quote here from
chris klein the ceo and co-founder of
bitcoin ira he says there seems to be a
range where bitcoin starts to look like
a game of pong there are headwinds
across markets not just in crypto we've
got inflation that is not transitory
there's uncertainty around rate hikes
and conversations about a recession
there's a lot of waiting on the
sidelines but of course just anecdotal
viewpoints is only one piece of the
puzzle if we go ahead and take a look at
these four charts it tells us even more
the first chart shows that online search
interest across bitcoin ethereum crypto
nft and metaversus is all down since the
start of the year the futures volumes
aren't recovering either those have been
trending downward as well if we then go
ahead and we take a look at crypto funds
assets under management you can see that
they've pretty much just gone sideways
for the last couple of months and then
the weekly flows to crypto etfs while
they are trending upwards slightly it's
still nothing like we saw last q3 of
2021. if we then take a look at liz
young from sofi she's a great point
which she stated that she tells people
that are interested in crypto that it's
okay to have a small portion of your
portfolio i don't think that it's an
asset class that's going away i do think
that it's here and it's here to stay but
it will go through a lot of different
price discovery phases in these next few
years ultimately that's what happens
with an asset that is going through
global adoption it goes up it goes down
sometimes with great volatility but as
you continue to think about what you at
home are doing are you a short-term
trader do you have the skills expertise
and experience to actually trade within
every hour or every day or are you
simply better off just dollar cost
averaging into an asset that you think
is great and trying to hold it forever
as warren buffett once said our favorite
holding time is forever and as i always
say dollar cost averaging into any asset
whether it's stocks bonds commodities
real estate or bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies is usually a foolproof
way to continue to simply use assets as
a savings tool in an environment where
inflation has run rampant hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time